I live in Brooklyn, New York.
I am Cuban/Nicaraguan and I work in book publishing.
I love taking pictures when I travel,...
...and it's incredibly important to capture all the moments that you're seeing.
Whenever I come back from a trip, I check all of my photos...
..and what's really exciting about Google Stories is that it kind of creates a memory,...
...sometimes better than I remember it.
In Europe, that was the first time I really felt the exhilaration you feel when you travel.
In Paris, I kissed Oscar Wilde's grave.
It's covered in like pink and red lips and I knew that I wanted my lip to be on there too.
When I travel, I feel like the ultimate version of myself.
It's about not holding yourself back, being excited and wanting to see everything...
...and just really understanding what it means to be alive.